foreign
there is an ugly storm brewing
financially there are some things going
on in the world that is setting us up
for some serious
who Financial failure here it says as
emergency savings drop and credit card
debt Rises an ugly stew is brewing
Warren's an advocate it says that as
high inflation continues and interest
rates go up many people are seeing their
savings dwindle and credit card balances
increase It also says as those debts
become more expensive delinquencies may
be poised to increase not maybe I'm
telling you they are on the rise we can
look and see that people are defaulting
on their credit cards defaulting on
their car loans at higher rates and
really like the Great Recession yeah
2008 2009 that's that's where we're at
right now so let me ask you this um you
look at this data much closer than I do
and it says this survey was
um done in January yep
when I hear household debt is rising at
to unprecedented levels and it was the
greatest holiday season ever that tells
me that inflation's hurting families yes
but that these expenses these extra debt
uh the debt accumulation across the
board now there's going to be individual
families people stuck in in systems I
get that but across the board this tells
me that people are propping up their
lifestyle they're not trying to buy eggs
and bacon and and rice they are trying
to keep their kids in all the travel
Sports and trying to keep their SUVs
full right so they're trying to pop up a
lifestyle with Dad yeah John in my mind
there's two schools of people here it's
like you said it's the folks who are
truly truly struggling like they're
they're they can't buy groceries right
right and then there's the people who
have just decided that this is a
bandwagon thing like oh helocs are cool
I'll get one I need a new kitchen oh
wait we can't like I'm just gonna get
the newest car I need a Tesla yeah sign
me up for for payments there's the
people who are just going along with
whatever culture says like this is the
life you need to live at any cost
basically and then when
the default starts happening when the
market starts turning when you realize
you're upside down on your car or you
went crazy in 2020 and you're realizing
you're upside down on your house you're
looking around trying to point the
finger but you can't because you chose
to go along with this I wish people
could hear our conversations I've had
conversations with Dave and he said the
words I'm not I'm not spending that on
that yeah it's people of means have
conversations and say less too much I'm
not going to pay that price for this or
I call the uh a guy who's gonna do some
work on my house yesterday and said I
can't afford this but I can afford this
one yeah so I'm gonna do this work but
not this work
but that's not a normal phrase right and
and I I we've got to take into account
things have gotten more expensive they
just have inflations real we have to
modulate and adjust our lifestyles man
or we're gonna have it's gonna be a mess
it it requires a certain level of
self-awareness it requires a certain
level of ownership of your own financial
situation because I mean we know
a lot of people most people aren't
living on a budget like to know how you
would be surprised when you ask somebody
on the street hey how much money do you
make people can't even answer that
question oh I think it's like I think
like when I get my checks I think it's
like like fourth out like people don't
know the answer 19 bucks an hour well
how much do you make like a month or a
year yeah I don't know yeah and the more
majority of people I write a stat it's
over 50 if you ask them hey what'd you
spend last month no clue I can't tell
you they can't tell you and and then
we're wondering okay why why is it that
our emergency savings is dropping why is
it that credit card debt is writing
Rising because if you're not aware if
you're not being a good Steward which is
simply being a good manager of the money
that's coming into your hands yeah
you're gonna spend too much of it and
then you're gonna go wait what do I do
oh I know credit card you're gonna make
ends meet with a credit card and then
when that runs out you're gonna go to
the next thing right and how many people
do you know who their car breaks down
yeah they don't have enough cash to get
it fixed so do you know what do you
don't do you know what people do John
they will go finance a new car
because that's it's just money
exchanging I'd Rather Go finance a new
car than shell out 800 to get my car
fixed I don't have any more room on my
credit cards to do that but I can trade
this car up and get a new one any role
that you roll the the negative equity
into your new yeah and then you're
running wondering why you're up a creek
you know yeah and then and there's a
note here in this in this I want to make
sure we touch on this younger workers or
more financially fragile
um what does that mean
well my guess is it means two things one
um they don't have the savings built up
and they are they are starting from a
they're starting from scratch if you
will and I think there's some probably
some truth to that okay and
um well it says 45 of Millennials 44 of
gen xers and 38 of ginsiers have more
credit card debt than money in savings
and so I left College my my with my
bachelor's degree this is this is 100
years ago so this sounds like no student
loan debt but at the time it was a
million bucks I left with 17 grand okay
in debt for my bachelor's degree
I finished my first year of working with
a great job 25 or 30 Grand in the hole
on credit card because I just said yes
to everything I wanted to do I feel that
YOLO I was gonna and so if you are a
young worker if you're in the first two
or three or four years out of college in
your first job
live a Spartan life and give yourself a
fighting chance to get ahead on the back
end right save and save and save get
roommates live cheap Drive used cars
nobody cares and if he or she does care
you don't want to date him anyway yeah
begin to make that part of your life so
that when these things happen when
you're 35 or 45
it's not so much that you have the money
is fine and the savings account's fine
all that it's you have changed your
character you just handle these problems
in a different way that's true that's a
really good point making that mental
shift early on it's an identity yeah I'm
not trying to live a life so that other
people can look at what I have and uh
getting my worth and my value from that
you know if you can start that mindset
younger the better and just on a
practical tip if you are young and you
have debt now is the time to get it like
Now's the Time to get after it and pay
it off do it before you get married do
it before you have kids because let me
tell you something the stuff that my
husband and I did to pay off debt it's a
lot easier to do when you don't have
kids oh man everything changes you got
kids man all that side hustling all
those those meals you know all that
stuff it's it's easier when you're on
your own and then it's easier when you
don't have kids don't get me wrong when
you have kids and all this you could
still do it but if you're one of these
Jen's years one of these gen xers and
you're you're struggling now is the time
to get after it do not wait do not put
it off please now is the a time to get
after that because this is this is a
this is a problem like they said it's an
ugly stew Brewing I think that's funny
that they wrote it like that but I mean
we get to choose that's the best part
about this John is we get to choose what
we're going to participate in and um you
don't have to participate in debt that's
optional right you know if you are one
of those folks who have found yourselves
out in the margins and you are really
struggling reach out for help let
somebody know I'm not all right I need
some support I need to figure something
else out I need uh call one of our
Ramsay coaches and get some get some
some direct support but if you're just
propping up a lifestyle man you gotta
choose reality you gotta choose reality
because reality is going to choose you
if you're not careful yeah and you can
stop today
listening to this show we'll talk we
will talk to you about budgets uh until
your ears fall off we will make sure you
understand what it takes for you to get
hold of your financial situation